ray Ratto was at the game last night the
Spurs and his dubs the Warriors and had
a little back-and-forth ray is a
reporter for Comcast SportsNet Bay Area
writer for them Seaton would you play
the little back and forth between ray
and Greg Popovich last night was it
immediately from the start that you saw
this or did it take a couple of mice and
hairs geez was it from the start no I
was at one minute and 37 seconds is when
we figured that out okay thank you or
maybe was three minutes three minutes
and then we realized okay come on ray
being the great reporter wants to know
when Pop realized that his team just
didn't have it and yes boy do you think
reporters are different when the Spurs
lose by 36 well I think you're you got a
little bit more confidence that you're
able to say something there let's bring
in ray Wright oh there they low back and
forth there I like that you said thank
you very very polite of you ray it was
really more back than 40 you try to go
fourth you wouldn't let you they all
know that it listen it I didn't think it
was a bad question but was probably
asked the wrong guy at the wrong time so
you know big deal known him for 35 years
and I wasn't trying to bait him in fact
interestingly later on somebody asked
Steph Curry a form of the same question
and got a pretty useful answer so you
know I just chose the wrong target and I
lived and he lived and we left about it
in all way and went off into the sunset
holding hands having a glass of wine
singing I am 16 going on 17 the Spurs in
Game one the injury with Kawhi Leonard
now I know that you cover the Warriors
for Comcast SportsNet Bay Area can you
separate not not saying allegiance but
at least you're around that team in the
play that happened with Pachulia if
you're just watching that as an innocent
bystander do you look at it differently
well I mean first of all I don't just
cover the I cover other stuff to our our
guy muddy pools numbers them all the
time and is really good I think it's
pretty well agreed
that while he wasn't trying though while
Pachulia wasn't trying to hurt Leonard
it was a pretty cynical foul and it
happens a lot and I think you know did
it change the series I don't think you
can argue that it didn't I mean I think
you know if it doesn't happen the Spurs
win Game one I don't think they win Game
two based on the fact that the Warriors
just came out and swallowed them from
the start but I you know I didn't get
caught up in the is he a dirty player
argument yeah you know is it a reckless
play yes is it a cynical act absolutely
but there's cynical acts all the time in
every NBA game in every hockey game and
every football game it is part of the
nature of playing sports for money so
you know he patchouli doesn't come off
as a hero or a genius he also doesn't
come off as a as an innocent here I mean
I just he knew that if he could make
Leonard land awkwardly it would at worse
than with it at least it would just it
would affect the shot so yeah I think he
knew what he was doing I think you know
had he had he had his choice he wouldn't
you know wouldn't have injured him but I
think you want to make him uncomfortable
and I think that goes on constantly in
every game what about Aldridge's play
last night on Durant and Durant did come
down on LaMarcus Aldridge his foot well
if Durant goes down you've got a
crapstorm of yeah nuclear force and it's
the risk that players are willing to run
especially in the playoffs remember a
couple of years ago when the new phase
in the NBA was hitting a guy in the
groin as he was coming around a screen
you know it it's stepping underneath a
guy a shooter I guess is the new version
of that you know I mentioned it's you
know it's a cynical play and you know
pros are cynical at times like this and
they're going to do hey I know my
predecessors have done this I know their
predecessors have done it this has been
going on in basketball since Hank lesedi
first jumped off the ground
so yeah I I guess maybe I'm too cynical
but I
I expect to see that he's a ray rod Oh
Comcast SportsNet Bay Area I stay with
me on this Kevin Durant can't just win a
championship and be part of the team is
there more pressure for Kevin Durant to
be a star of a championship team instead
of just somebody who joined a team
that's going to win a title if you
follow me on this yeah I do and what
kind of question is that I mean you know
what if I go analyzer yes mom it feels
really good on the other side job I
actually don't think there is more
pressure on him um I think he came to
the Warriors knowingly because it wasn't
going to sit all on him I mean the
Warriors all have pressure because they
failed last year you know Cleveland beat
them and they thought that title was
theirs
so they've all got this on them if they
don't win this year yeah you know
nobody's going to say gee was is Durant
have more pressure on him than curry no
it's going to be a collective nightmare
but it's also going to be a collective
triumph if they all win so I don't think
Durant has more pressure on him than
curry does then green does I I think
it's it's a shared experience and I
think that's probably one of the reasons
why he came there to begin with it it
wasn't going to be the defining moment
for Kevin Durant it was going to be a
defining moment for this franchise the
difference between being a budding
dynasty and a one-hit wonder good luck
with the back-and-forth Game three in
San Antonio by the way Steve Kerr's
availability at all is there any update
on him coaching the rest of the
postseason there's no official update
but I would be surprised if he if he
coached I mean until until the moment
that he's absolutely symptom free
I think he's got too many people telling
him to stay what you know you don't have
to do this you know and I think you know
I think one of the great unknown forces
here is his wife who
you know just you know she doesn't put
pressure but she's going to give him
that wifely look that goes really you
got a headache and you're still going to
go do this again you know use your head
you know I mean I'm frankly you know I'm
grateful to Mark Cuban that he's turned
the conversation around from everything
because that that what did you make of
that right that's the best part of the
whole day what I make of it is it's an
owner's fascination with showing us how
how the sausage is made and in the past
that was the last thing an owner wanted
to do I mean a year ago you know Jerry
Jones was basically explaining how the
NFL owners screwed the Chargers and
Raiders out of LA and did so in pretty
significant detail and now this year
it's Mark Cuban explaining that when you
pay your ticket for a regular-season
game we kind of consider you a sucker
but they're fine with that because they
get to say hey this is how it really
works as though the fascination with
ownership is more important than the
fascination with the game it's it's a
great statement of of narcissism that
frankly I think owners feel a lot better
with now than they ever have before it
hey here's something cynical that we do
all the time come I'll show you how we
do it
I mean it's madness but it's great you
think the league responds I think
they'll probably choke him oh yeah yeah
Adam silver is now firing down advil
like their pegs but you know that's the
price he pays for dealing with those 13
maniacs every day thank you Ray all
righty that's ray Ratto Comcast
SportsNet Bay Area he's a funny dude
funny dude the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you